[ __ ] is one you think a girl and a boy
are perfect together and you put their
two names together hi
a lot of the boys are very shy and a lot
of the girls are very talkative
most of the boys have crushes on girls
let's say this is a girl and this is a
boy my best friend Michael I promised to
get him bowling man and he was my
wingman's like wingman the wingman well
there's one boy that we know has a crush
on she has a crush on him
everyone knows that it's just they don't
know it well the one who picks on
everybody she said it to me that he had
a crush on me
some boys I mean it's our girls when
they're like that so they think they'll
get hanging around with them more that's
not the way they get them to like you
bad you have to show respect of kindness
me and my other couple friends we went
up to Ariana and we're like talk to ISA
so she said hi and they started talking
and then a week I'm up because she
walked away and she said he said no and
turns me down so we're like what I think
third grade goes us flatter most boys
now in my class respect girls some was
just aren't like that they think it's a
low that kissing but it's really part of
life you know